a fire has broken out at a fuel Depot in
Russia's Southern crust across nodar
region the governor said a drone attack
caused it near the Russian Annex Crimea
region Charles Stratford is joining us
from the Ukrainian Capital Kiev to tell
us more about uh what we're learning
about this fire
well very little information coming
through so far but as you say there has
seemed to be some sort of explosion
that's occurred at a fuel Depot in
krasnodar that's from Mainland Russia
very close to the entrance of the Kirch
bridge that connects Mainland Russia
with the Crimean Peninsula all we've
heard from Russian authorities certainly
according to the regional Governor he's
saying that this fire is what he
describes as being at the highest level
of difficulty in trying to extinguish it
but of course it comes in the wake of
those attacks we saw a couple of days
ago which certainly the Russians
reported as being attacks on a major
Fuel Depot in Sebastopol on Mainland
Crimea close to the very important
obviously port for the Russians Black
Sea Fleet again the ukrainians today
we've heard nothing from them any kind
of official confirmation or comment on
these suspected attacks but it wouldn't
be inconceivable that the was an attack
we have seen an increase in recent days
from certainly from the Ukrainian side
these these suspected attacks on Russian
targets and it's a similar scenario as
well with missile and drone attacks from
the Russian side of various locations
deep inside Ukraine there were another
26 so-called Kamikaze drones launched by
Russia last night 21 of which so the
ukrainians say were intercepted and of
course if you look at this in the
context of what's expected to be a major
counter-offensive by the ukrainians in
the days and weeks ahead these kind of
tit-for-tat attacks would not be
inconceivable seemingly Russia trying to
hit Ukrainian supply lines and the
ukrainians trying to potentially hit
fuel Depots so important obviously for
the Russians as they dig in their
defensive positions in expectation for
this counter-offensive all right thank
you so much Charles Stratford from Kiev